Ronnie's in Minnesota hey Ronnie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you so
much for taking my call um I just
started recently recently listening to
you and I have a couple of quick
questions okay so I want to know what a
money market account is specifically
yoga okay
typically what a money market account is
is a branding thing at your local bank
it's a savings account that pays more
than a typical savings account the
actual money market account is an
account where you're actually buying
into the currency money market and you
can't get that through a bank or credit
union but you'll hear every bank and
credit union has a money market account
and all that means is it's tied to the
interest rate is similar to what you
would get if you went like to a mutual
fund company like fidelity or American
or you went to Vanguard you can get a
real money market account where you're
actually buying into the money markets
in those through those mutual fund
companies but that it's irrelevant
whether you do that or whether you do
the bank the bank's actually got a FDIC
guarantee on it or a mutual fund don't
but it doesn't matter
it's gonna pay a little bit more about
it's gonna pay about what CD rate is if
it's a decent one a little bit more than
and so you know instead of a half a
percent you might get one one and a
quarter right or they offer you some
introductory yeah yeah like a three
percent introductory rate but at two
months that's that's that's just a big
switch no but yeah that's all the money
market is when you hear money market
it's it's if it's at a bank it's an
account that actually simulates or
mirrors what the real money markets are
doing but there's no difference it might
be an eighth of a percent difference or
something it's not relevant that the
interest rate sucks on all of this none
of this you used to get rich you don't
use sudhi's to it rich you don't use
money markets to get rich and you're
sure as crowd don't use the savings
account to get rich this is a place
you're parking money while you're saving
it for Christmas barking money for your
emergency fund and that
great day Dave I like that it's a
parking spot that's it it is and it's
still liquid though so you can get to it
Ronnie so if you have an emergency you
get into it but guess what you want to
replace that money so you always have it
at all times yeah and it's just a higher
interest rate savings account yeah it's
always I would look at it from a
practical standpoint yeah and obviously
there's technical details to the
definition other than that but that's
that's the way I'd look at it yeah Dave
we're country folk that's the gist the
gist we just told you tucky Tennessee
thing that's exactly right just wood